you said you lost your father four years
ago yeah
what have you learned about life from
your dad that's another another big one
yeah because I was very close to him
and uh it was tough it was tough
and I was not
I was a sort of not ready for it because
up until that point I lived pretending
that death does not exist
when my grandparents died
I was already in the US
so it's very convenient and I couldn't
go back so I grieved but it kind of was
a bit abstract for me I didn't see their
dead bodies you know I didn't
bury them and so on so I waited till so
my the first death in my life was my
father
like of a really close loved ones and I
was absolutely devastated
you know he was such an amazing creature
such an amazing human being he was the
kindest the smartest the most funny just
it's really funny and just really fun to
be with you know this is what I miss
obviously I mean I was just love to hang
out with him
so and then suddenly it's not there
so it's tough but it kind of changed my
perspective you miss him
I miss him tremendously
I miss him tremendously but I in a way I
learned that he never left me in some I
mean it sounds so uh words are so you
know like they are
they cannot express in words this what
I'm trying to say but
um do you carry him
with you yeah but in some sense I always
did and and I
I
saw that that it's always been
um it was really we were one in some
sense you know like we were but there
was this experience of
two two people
being together and that I missed
tremendously
but he gave me so much and I you know
let me tell you one aspect of it for
instance
when he was a kid his father was sent to
Gulag on bogus pretenses right so he
when he was 16 he replied to a
university he wanted to become a
theoretical physicist
by the way my love for critical physics
was the large extent
because of that
and he was not accepted even though he
was brilliant because he was the son of
the enemy of the people
and he
kind of broke him this experience that
he
didn't care when he was you know he went
to technical school and he didn't really
care that's my take on it
and then he ended up in this in this in
this little provincial town
and he thought he would escape from it
as soon as possible and then he met my
mother and they fell in love
and so I am sort of the product the
product of that you know of physics but
then
what I learned is that
because he was not able to overcome that
specific experience
it felt to me to do it and if I didn't
my son of my daughter would have I think
that that was one of the things I
learned
that was not by chance that our about
the same age
for slightly different reasons I was
subjected to the same kind of unfairness
and cruelty
and I in some ways I I feel like I did
it for him also I always because he was
also always so proud of me I was so
happy and I was I had this tremendous
gift
twice I was invited by American
mathematical Society
to give this big lectures twice it was
in 2012 and in 2018.
and both times they were in Boston it
could be anywhere in the U.S both times
was in Boston walking distance from my
parents place
so he could be there in my mom as well
and that was such a gift that he was
beaming you know like seeing me on the
stage
so
you know
now that he's no longer here and it's
just you
more like I would still have my mom I
still have my sister yeah but as a man
yeah there's some aspect that it's
um
that it does hit you hard
um are you afraid of your own death do
you think about your death
are you afraid of it I have a certain
conceptual view of life and death today
which is informed by my experiences in
particular going through my father's
death
and that is something which cannot be
conceptualized like that experience like
it could not give it to somebody
one thing I will say
is that I felt that what it was it was
actually love totally exposed like naked
and you try to throw it is so acute so
being facing that love
is incredibly painful because it's so
intense
one person is alive
we're we have conversation we have wars
we have some actions we have some stuff
is going on and it puts a filter so you
we rarely actually feel love and it's
totally completely pure and adulterated
state but when person dies it's there
and it's staring at you and no matter
what you do you cannot run away like I
try to it's like almost I felt like I
want to throw a blanket over it yeah you
it burns like immediately like boom gone
it's there
live through it and I was I kept saying
to myself I just live through it live
through it that's how you and that's how
you know also learn what is love for
example what is it really
what is love what is life also because I
was completely
I had no idea and
and then you kind of learn that okay so
maybe it's not quite
there is more to fit the more there is
more to eat there's more to this
experience than what can be put in a
concept or in a in a in a sentence in
this in a maybe poetry or music uh can
do some justice to it but if so then my
own life has that component has that
Dimension which is beyond anything I can
say about it you know and even though I
love this being this playing this role I
love it
and I kind of
kind of makes me feel different about
all kinds of difficulties that arise
because it's almost like I want to enjoy
it because that's what being human is
it's being it's being terrified it's
being frustrated it's being
self-loathing sometimes it's not knowing
but also being joyful and just like
ah let's just enjoy it kind of all of it
like that's why you came here for in
some sense you know
it's like not trying to run away from
things but kind of trying to just live
through them and appreciate so the
biggest thing is gratitude in some sense
it's just gratitude so thank you for
letting me play yeah this is gratitude
for every single moment even if it's
dark even if it's lost and that's why I
am so people around me they will say
that it's a total Doom and Gloom and the
world is ending and I'm like
first of all that's how you see it okay
that's not the only point of view but
also even if it is like that's your
challenge like what are you going to do
about it stop complaining about other
people do something yourself how can you
make it a better world you know and I
think all of that starts with just a
gratitude for the moment to be able to
play this game yeah how beautiful it is
what uh we've talked about love but let
me ask what role does Love play in this
whole game in The Human Condition
it's like the glue you know it's like
for me it's like that
it's and it's not because people say
love is like for a human being like a
romantic love yeah which is huge a
component of it obviously because so so
beautiful to be able to to express it in
this way but it could be love for what
you do for your passion for something
you know and uh
or
or love for for your for your friends
for instance or love it doesn't have to
be and so in some sense that's that's
what it's all about in ultimately
because
Living Without Love it's kind of Bland
boring and so
I don't think it's possible for science
to explain exactly what it is you can do
uh evolutionary biology perspective you
can talk about some kind of Sociology
perspective psychology perspective but
the experience of where you forget or
time we're reminded becomes an illusion
and everything just freezes
and then uh it's kind of beautiful and
painful to hear you say that when you've
experienced love
the deepest is when you lost it yes but
in a sense you can say that
you could not have one without the other
I could not have that deep connection
with my father like really on so so many
levels
if they weren't the moment that's how I
see it and I'm not trying to say that's
how everybody should see for instance I
respect I respect and I feel and I
almost like I I feel good when I'm not
right now I feel
that desire to reconnect
even if it is in the form of a you know
a computer program let's be honest about
it I find it to be very moving I find it
very moving and I understand because he
actually didn't have a chance to spend
much time you know I think he was 16 or
something when he's he was a teenager
he's dead I was lucky because my father
died I was much older I've had so many
moments with him but that's not my thing
like I think it is the feature it's not
a bug and it sounds crazy like I would
love I would give anything to have him
here right now right now I everything I
have I give it away right now yeah where
do I sign yeah just see him for one hour
I promise you I will
but I also know that I it then I'll
still lose him
or I will die or whatever you know so
that thing so what is why is it so worse
to just hold hold on to holding on to it
why why are we holding on to this and I
am the first sucker I'm not the first
man to hold on but I'm questioning it
now like is there another way to
approach life where you just you know
Buddha it's like
enjoy
and let it go enjoy and let it go is it
possible except the Paradox of it well
ask me in a couple of years you know I
will report but I think that it but to
my mathematical mind yeah it sounds like
a very interesting idea to be honest
because to me the idea of holding isn't
it sounds like an impasse because no
matter in all my experience and if you
look in history every time somebody's
holding you know it's how they said in
The Matrix whatever has a beginning has
an end it's like you cannot go around it
if you have a beginning you could have
an end so then might as well just enjoy
it and not worry too much about
extending it longer
that's how I see it now but maybe
tomorrow will be something else you know
yeah the roller coaster life the Paradox
of life right Edward you're an
incredible human being I've been a fan
for a long time thank you for writing
love and math thank you thank you for
being who you are being uh both one of
the greatest living mathematicians and
still
childlike Wander of the uh exploring the
how this whole world works the the
nature of the universe and thank you so
much for speaking with me today this is
amazing
been a pleasure thank you